[Musique]
bonsoir tout le monde merci d'être là
pour nous toutes et tous
quand béatrice dubois c'est ma proposé
d'intervenir pour l'été dit que sur la
mixité un père musulman une mère juive
une origines sociales modestes
un petit chemin de parvenus de petite
bourgeoise parisienne je me suis dit bon
c'est pour moi j'ai gardé mes notes avec
moi ce que je suis et motive le seul
problème c'est que j'ai du mal à prendre
la parole en public et en plus ma tâche
mais en bonne juive je me suis réveillé
avec 39 de fièvre je vous demandais un
tout petit peu d'indulgence
donc j'ai comme je disais j'ai été élevé
dans une cité à la courneuve ou bien que
la mairie communiste ce soit bien occupé
de nous je me faisais souvent un peu
chiant je déchire unique
et puis j'avais pas 14 ans j'avais
plutôt 8,9 en émoi la pète un peu mais
j'ai découvert babcock babcock c'est
quoi c'est d ancien entrepôt reconverti
en bibliothèque je suis rentré dans la
bibliothèque
et là j'ai découvert vraiment c'est vrai
j'ai découvert peau bouille d'emile zola
oh oui c'est quoi c'est les rougon
macquart
et là je découvre que les riches peuvent
être pauvre je découvre un autre monde
c'est à dire que la richesse de façade
derrière les façades haussmanniennes il
peut y avoir de la pauvreté humaine
là ça y est j'ai été mordu comme l'a dit
arnaud j'ai plongé dans la littérature
des gratuits et silencieux et pas cher
non et là je me suis mis à dévorer les
livres et comme à quelque chose malheur
est bon
travaillant bien à l'école aimant les
livres
l'ascenseur social s'est naturellement
ouvert devant moi je suis monté bons
résultats au bac désectorisation
sorbonne maîtrise dea dss ce que j
oublie de mentionner c'est que ma
première année de deug j'arrive et là il
ya une fille de ministre lafitte
chevènement pour pas la nommer
qui me dit tu as quand même un phrasé
particulier
tu es vraiment une fille des rues donc
c'est vrai que j'arrive de la courneuve
tous les soirs je rentre à la courneuve
fait mon trajet en rer à pied en métro
trajet est long de la terre à la lune
et là je lui mets une droite et là vous
me croirez ou pas mais c'est vrai la
fille villeroy et boch est en deug de
lettres avec moi qui s'appelait juliette
qui était très sympa l'été anorexique
comme moi donc ça nous faisait des liens
elle vient vers moi et puis elle me dit
fais très gars parce que les pauvres ça
cogne avec les points mais les riches
avec les avocats
je me suis dit à ce manquement à ce
moment là que la mixité sociale
ce serait pas pour tout de suite je
continue mes études des ssd à roanne
d'arbres à wonder bras stagiaires dans
la pub assistante de frédéric beigbeder
pour pas le nommer j'ai décidé de
balancer tout le monde ce soir
voilà on vient me voir et puis on me
tend une annonce qui dit le 4 mai
n'diaye c'est le cas millar me regarde
moi dans les yeux du mot que tu m'aimes
wonderbra on me dit toi la stagiaire tu
fais des lettres traduit nous sommes
français étudiait pas la langue anglaise
mais pourquoi pas et là je dis bah
regardez moi dans les yeux j'ai dit les
yeux prix internationaux à cannes etc
évidemment je n'ai pas là le la
récompense je retourne finir mon
doctorat
mais quand même j'entame une carrière
dans la publicité parce que le patron
pascal manry de l'agencé tbw à l'époque
montrent fcb et me dit je vais donner
dix mille francs par mois pour venir
faire des petites phrases de rédactrices
et pour moi dix mille francs par mois
moi qui étais boursière c'était le graal
je cesse mon doctorat je commence une
carrière dans la pub
j'ai raconté tout ça dans un livre qui
s'appelle pas parce d'authoring stone
jeu les adapter au cinéma
j'ai raconté aussi dans ce livre est
dans ce film que j'ai quitté la pub à
l'âge de 39 ans après un divorce un burn
out une garde alternée non voulues et
c'est bon et là j'ai commencé à faire ce
que j'avais vraiment envie de faire
c'est à dire raconté
l'avis de mes contemporains raconter
quelque chose qui me tient à coeur c'est
qu'est ce que c'est qu'être un citoyen
français qu'est ce que c'est kate une
petite française de banlieue dans la
france d'aujourd'hui
le livre a du succès le film aussi et
puis récemment depuis un an à peu près
je suis régulièrement invité par des
mairies dernièrement à lyon et à
grenoble ont projeté mon film dans les
salles et puis ensuite animé des débats
et là je découvre dans les quartiers les
quartiers populaires j'allais dire de
lyon un monde fait de favelas s'inscrit
et moi mais pas appeler ça autrement
avec des enfants qui sont complètement
déconnectés de l'école trois quarts des
foyers qui sont monoparentaux et puis
une désaffection de tout ce qui moi m'a
tenu debout c'est à dire les valeurs de
la république en mai note donc je
commence à discuter avec ces jeunes j'ai
animé beaucoup beaucoup de débats c'est
pour ça que je peux vous en parler ce
soir
et puis là on me dit mais ya pas de
boulot la france est de la merde
les juifs y sont riches les noirs ipu
les arabes ils ont tous voilée ils vont
tous nous crever donc tout le monde en
avait après tout le monde en fait
et là je me dis bah merde alors je
commence à raconter j'ai dit moi j'ai
grandi dans les années 80 or comme à
rome ouais à une époque où la publicité
chantait des chansons où on avait des
petites mains jaunes la touche pas à mon
pote ou les filles n'étaient pas voilées
mon s'en foutait où on faisait le
ramadan qui pousse mélanger les uns les
autres on envoyait des sacs de riz en
afrique on sait jamais s'ils sont
arrivés ou pas en tout état de cause
ça circulait on allait les uns vers les
autres alors c'était pas parfait je peux
pas vous dire clavier la courneuve
c'était le club med mais quand même et
sa gelée racontée dans le livre on a
quand même bien ri et surtout on allait
les uns vers les autres
donc j'ai discuté avec ces jeunes là
j'ai discuté avec des élus locaux
et là les élus locaux me dit vous êtes
vous accrocher pas mal les jeunes qu'est
ce que vous pourriez proposé pour que
les gens aillent les uns vers les autres
alors moi je dis
moi je suis pas le messie donc j'ai pas
j'ai pas de solution mais déjà si on
commençait à partager à puis merde on sa
purée pas sûr quand même ce que ce pays
a de magnifiques les valeurs de la
république la france c'est quoi moi je
voyage dans le monde entier
je voyage beaucoup la france c'est la
cmu ou l'aide médicale universelle c'est
un cas unique au monde
n'importe qui ça date de napoléon qui
traverse ce pays peut se faire soigner
gratuitement la france c'est quoi c'est
de pouvoir étudier gratuitement et mieux
un jour à new york alors que je disais
qu'on me payait pour étudier on n'a pas
cru moi j'avais trois mille francs par
mois par trimestre par nom de 1930 un
trimestre pour pouvoir aller étudier à
la sorbonne puis pendant longtemps
j'essaye d'expliquer ça aux jeunes et la
solution que ggg soumises je sais pas si
elle est bonne mais pour commencer à se
réapproprier le drapeau qui fait l'unité
de ce pays sa mixité justement cette
mosaïque de cultures de langues parce
qu'on a tous des origines plus ou moins
diverses et bigarré de cuisine de région
la france en soit c'est un pays mosaïque
la france en soit c'est un pays tout
petit où il ya tous les paysages où
historiquement il ya plusieurs langues
qui cohabitent
j'ai évoqué ce truc là et pourquoi j'ai
pensé à ça alors on m'a dit oh la la
marine le pen
hélas non l'ag paraphraser romain gary
et j'ai dit attendez faut que je me
souvienne
le patriotisme c'est l'amour des siens
le nationalisme c'est la haine de
l'autre
applaudissez
[Applaudissements]
j'ai plus de salive donc je reprends mes
notes pour récupérer bien sûr elles sont
dans le désordre
donc ma solution c'est ça c'est une
solution un peu bêta mais je pense que
nous les mamans et même les papas ici on
à ce devoir de redonner les valeurs de
la patrie à nos enfants
moi je n'avais pas de pair là vous
pleuré j'ai grandi sans père et mon père
pour moi c'était c'est quoi ce téléphone
télé bourse que je recevais c'est le
fait que quoi qu'il arrive je sais à peu
près que mon pays ne me laissera pas
tomber mon père c'est quoi c'est quand
je me suis retrouvé viré de la pub à 39
en train de divorcer que des frais
d'avocat et de gosse en bas âge ces 23
mois d'assedic basse et j'ai pas vu ça
beaucoup sur la planète
voilà donc je voudrais juste qu'on
rappelle sa à la jeunesse de ce pays qui
désespère un peu la jeunesse des
quartiers parce que vraiment je les
rencontre et est vraiment j'ai été saisi
par le désamour de ses enfants pour leur
pays pour leur nation
il ya une petite blague qui me dit
maintenant madame bon je vais te dire -
attends moi quand je marche dans la rue
à lyon après quand je monte l'ascenseur
c'est comme si je prends l'avion
et quand je rentrerai au sénégal chez
moi je dis mais c'est bien juste quand
tu es dans la rue c'est de regarder
autour et c'est de voir ce que les colts
offre accroche toi à l'école ouais mais
je suis noir je m'étais moi j'étais dans
une cité 93120 la courneuve
c'était chaud aussi pour le cv mais
accroche toi ta récompense elle lance
elle n'en sera que plus savoureuse jeu
pour finir je voudrais vous montrer
l'image d'une femme l hymne elle et elle
est née en tunisie elle est venue en
france à l'âge de 32 ans
elle et elle était très attachée à son
pays
l arrivée en france et elle a embrassé
les valeurs de ce pays cette femme c'est
ma grand-mère à la 93 ans peut pas être
là aujourd'hui et nous a appris ses dix
enfants
ces 28 petits enfants pas les arrières
petits-enfants elle nous a appris à
aimer ce pays al inspecté à voir ce
qu'il avait de beaux elle a été
récompensée il ya quelques années
d'une seule diplôme quel âge avait eu
c'est la médaille d'or de la famille
française et je suis très fière d'elle
et jude et 10e son intervention à stx et
je vous embrasse
[Musique]